Hello?
Oh yeah.
Okay!
All right!
We're ready to go!
Accessibility means a lot of things.
Sometimes it means a user cannot see or hear.
Sometimes it means a user does
not speak your language.
And with that, we're actually going to have
a talk
that is live translated.
We have Felipe and Anna, and they're going
to be
talking about accessibility and JavaScript.
Side by side.
Yeah.
People think that this is like...
Sometimes people think that other
people are going to solve this problem, but
we're here to encourage you to
take this on yourself.
Just be like...
Take On Me, accessibility.
Get ready
for this.
All the way from Brazil, Felipe de Albuquerque.
Please applaud!
Hello, everybody here.
Today I...
I don't speak English fluently, but I
bring in this amazing topic, and I have my
wife too.
She's my boss at the work
at home.
She's my manager of my life.
And we stay here to talk to you about
this incredible...
Topic.
Accessibility in JS.
We'll start now.
First of all, I...
Just to say thank
you for the JS conference organization, and
CESAR, and all my sponsors, and
so...
Thank you all for coming.
It's our pleasure to be here.
Okay?
Let's get
started now.
Oh yeah.
Keep going.
Who here never listens to any joke about JavaScript?
Along the years, I
working with JavaScript, I listen to many
lies about JavaScript.
And today, I
stand here for talk to you, and try to clean
these bad reputation.
Because
JavaScript is a good guy.
Not bad guy.
Because I'm still here.
With all my
family.
And this amazing placing.
Because JavaScript...
Any other things, but
I...
I keep going.
Yeah.
Because now meeting the...
Too short.
30 minutes.
Keep going.
On the agenda for today...
Why I stay here for talk about accessibility.
Why should I invest in a little...
Why?
Around the world, according to
the UN,
have... 6,000...
650 million
650 million people have some kind of special
needs.
And in my country, it's
45 million.
It mean...
Represents almost a quarter...
23% of the population.
For me, it sounds...
Great opportunity at business.
In another...
Thinking out the box, can be exclude for the
great minds.
Minds.
Sorry, people.
It's...
English is not my maternal language.
Native.
Yeah.
But...
A strongly...
All of you should already...
They know.
I think the...
It's okay.
I think if anybody...
If nobody matter about him.
A lot of things that we would have lost.
You
can also think about Beethoven.
Most of the songs that he has written...
And
then once he couldn't hear anything, then
that's when he wrote his most
beautiful songs.
Another means...
And can we imagine if people didn't care about
songs written by people that
could not hear at all?
That did not happen.
So Beethoven turned out to be one
of the most famous composers of all time.
We need to think out the box.
And sometimes I try to talk about
accessibility for another guys, another develops
guy, and anybody...
No
matter, because it can be a tough...
Into a...
Anybody don't know about
accessibility's effect.
Most people don't really know what accessibility
is all about.
What is accessibility?
It's nothing to do, because it's not accessible
--
many guys try to make the application accessible,
but...
It has nothing to do with this image, at all.
(laughing)
And I...
I just to say for you...
Anything is accessible that cannot be
improved.
Yeah, that's what's written over there.
Accessibility...
Because we at times thinking about the...
(speaking Portuguese)
It's our new project to try to change.
Because it...
We need to see it
another way.
Because those peoples are able and active
and independent and
engaged.
Many disability people are engaged in...
(speaking Portuguese)
Yeah, just think about Stephen Hawking and
that's it.
And many other people.
But who needs accessibility?
We always...
Fought
about accessibility.
And blind people -- but it's not one.
Not just one.
But
it's all time...
We thought about...
It's necessary to think about temporary
disability.
Um...
When you get injured, and then maybe any of
you guys here could be in
that situation.
And perhaps need some kind of...
Accessible feature.
All that is about the interaction design.
Because the most important
technology is not technology.
Keep going.
But it's people.
Innovations are made for people.
(speaking Portuguese)
Innovation is made from people to people.
And another one...
It's colorblind people.
Many levels...
Colors...
Somebody...
Who can't see the right colors.
And people for different ages and countries,
and...
Yeah, kids, for instance.
So, for example, our kids -- when they didn't
know how to write, they would just touch the
speech button on the search
place, in the application, and they would
scream out the name of the...
(imitating kid)
Yeah, Let It Go!
Frozen!
Perfectly worked.
Oh, thank god.
I don't need to
write it now.
We need to think about the peoples -- don't
listen, don't written.
Hearing.
How do you say...
So yeah, don't forget about people who can't
listen.
Can't hear.
Because --
always remember that they might need subtitles,
or even the transcriptions
that they have here.
>>(speaking Portuguese)
I have just said that, baby.
Sorry.
Yeah.
People can feel...
Essential things about the documentation.
It's the most
important, because we need to know about the
documentation, but it's...
(speaking Portuguese)
Even though it's extremely rich...
Very rich...
Some people might get scared, because it's
an alphabet soup.
Many...
But today we're focusing...
Focusing...
On the accessibility,
because we too need our applications.
And this Y-ARIA.
It's the most important.
Because all of the JavaScript --
I will be talking along this presentation.
I just...
To help the WCAG...
It's divided into four basic principles.
Yes.
The perceivable...
Perceivable.
Understandable.
Operable.
And robust.
Perceivable is distinguishable information.
We need
to provide alternative texts, in the application
-- adaptable.
Adaptable...
Is
actually...
Is many...
Talk about responsive web design.
And other things.
Operable -- the application needs...
Navigate for keyboard, because some
people don't...
Can...
Can use an application with the mouse.
The mouse.
And to...(speaking Portuguese)
There are people who can even wear gadgets
on their heads, and use them to
access their applications.
But normally, those people use that...
The tab or enter...
Yeah.
That seems strange, but some people still
like to use the keyboard to
navigate their websites.
Most important of that --
The third point.
Is because...
What do you want to say?
>>(speaking Portuguese)
These may cause seizures.
So you need to be careful about the colors
you
use.
If it's blinking too much.
Yeah.
(speaking Portuguese)
Some people develop some applications, some
games or something really
interactive...
With lights blinking all the time, to emphasize
something.
But
there's a recommendation that says that you
cannot blink more than three times
per second.
Because that can provoke seizures.
And also the color combination
-- because if there's a red light blinking
too much...
People can also...
It
can cause also...
Seizures.
This is the most extreme case.
Never play a game in a long time, enough that...
Get a little bit dizzy.
You may get a little bit dizzy.
Because that stimulate light...
Yeah.
Keep going.
That's okay.
Understandable.
This is very understandable.
Because WCAG is
-- no application could be...
Legible.
Predictable, and has its input -- you're going
to explain a little bit more
in future.
This one I can tell that it's kind of -- the
God of software
development.
Because this is what everybody wants.
Is that your application
works in every single device.
Yeah.
Every resolution.
In all browsers.
Platforms.
Everywhere.
That's very difficult.
But can be possible.
And that requires a lot of effort, right?
We can do it.
Yes, we can.
User agents -- do you know them?
Because user agents -- this guy can be a
user agent.
Normally blind people use this guy, but this
guy can be
inaccessible, because this guy is...
Very...
Expensive.
Is many expense.
Because this guy is very training.
Very...
It requires a lot of training.
So in Brazil, for instance, it can cost you
like $60,000 Brazilian reals.
What would be $20,000 US.
So that's not
accessible at all.
But normally...
With...
We are used to...
To interact with browser.
Never has a problem with how long the software
development...
In using browsers.
The different browsers.
(speaking Portuguese)
Our big...
Something...
That we're really scared about some time ago.
The
reality is changing.
A little bit better.
But we still face a lot of problems,
when developing with browsers.
Understand the engine of the browser is very
difficult, but...
(speaking Portuguese)
Yeah.
Sometimes we cannot sleep at night.
Just thinking about the solution
to resolve this problem.
But normally we usually...
The text-to-speech...
Application.
I bring to you...
Yeah, you can see the disc.
Because to know how old that is.
Left, top.
So you can see how old this is.
Technology.
It's really...
The application, in transforming in voice.
And...
Our
researches about the most of...
Most used screen readers.
Thank you, baby.
Thank you, sweetie.
And in other ways...
I brought this here.
This slide is more specifically, because...
Some
people ask Felipe, why are you worrying about
accessibility?
In mobile
applications?
Why would a blind person use it in their mobile
device?
Right?
And I would like to answer to those people...
That the same way that we use
it, they can also use it.
It's a change in the mindset.
Right?
It's a human...
It's a human right.
Basic human right.
Yeah.
(speaking Portuguese)
And in this slide, I brought to you...
To show you what we would need to do
to make it compatible with...
To connect with -- now our user agent.
We have to do more.
Because we have
to teach now a browser, now a user agent...
(speaking Portuguese)
'til they can actually speak.
We need to teach the user agents how to
speak.
This is not actually very difficult.
So if you can observe this code
I've written, it's a very extremely basic
html.
But it is...
The kickoff
point.
A starting point.
Some people make some basic mistakes when
they're
writing their code.
They don't care, or they forget to set up
the correct doc
type, or even the language.
It can screw everything up.
If you do not set it
up in the way that the screen reader can use
it, the screen reader will try to
read your text in a language which is different
from the one you had set.
So
it's going to screw everything up.
The types...
The title.
Is the first thing the browser choose to say,
to
read the page.
And other means.
How various entry JavaScript and accessibility
-- I need to have for Minnesota University...
I read in the paper of them...
Say...
I sum up that...
And four principal barriers, my vision about
all the
saying the...
To read about the...
About that.
And the first one is...
The
browsers don't support JavaScript or have
disability...
Disabled JavaScript.
It's a big lie.
But it's...
Today, it's a big lie.
A long time ago, it's a
many...
It's a...
Half truth.
But today you can see that 97% of the browsers
support
JavaScript.
Standing here today for say to you, and my
Grandma use JavaScript, and she
don't know about
it mean.
That's right.
This is not fair with JavaScript.
To blame JavaScript.
And...
For another 2%...
We need to...
Give them some alternative.
So that they don't...
Okay.
It's
a little bit difficult...
It's...
Yeah, anybody use.
Not even Microsoft wants to give support to
it.
But yes...
Nightmare.
A long time ago.
Thank God I don't need to worry about it anymore.
Another code is Microsoft dev -- is...
We have to think out the box in a
novel approach, because...
To think...
About what?
How can I say that?
>>(speaking Portuguese)
About the identify browsers.
Oh, how to identify browsers.
So you would write different code, depending
on the browser that you would be using.
But instead of that, Microsoft has
designed a code that would detect the features
compatibility instead of
browsers.
Another here is...
Lack of knowledge of the ARIA.
ARIA...
ARIA for Mozilla
devs...
This is what they talk about.
ARIA is between accessibility...
Between accessibility and JS.
What connect accessibility and JS.
If it did
not exist, JavaScript could not work with
accessibility at all.
That's the work flow.
How it's working.
User agents...
Interact.
With the assistive technology.
Able for standard of ARIA.
One of
my heroes, who did the JQuery.
I have already earned a lot of money from
JQuery, thanks to him.
JQuery is a top technology.
Another amazing...
Like the (inaudible).
Today
in our life is a very...
Easy.
But the guys for me...
A big honor of the
amazing frameworks.
This is the language --
Just forgot to mention what he said on the
previous slide.
It's already
implemented.
So it's not a dream.
Right?
This is the rules of ARIA.
Thank you.
ARIA is able...
To say...
The
browsing and other user agents -- technology
for the piece of the code, HTML5
is the most semantic, but this is able really
semantic to for...
Almost...
All
the engines.
Rich internet application with AJAX.
AJAX of the old time --
but...
Five minutes?
Oh, no!
It's amazing.
We know about the AJAX, I think,
so...
Or somebody used...
Don't know about that.
This is my hero too.
ARIA
live is the only way for interactive application,
rich applications, to...
(speaking Portuguese)
The only thing that can really enable...
Because the big problem is that
the browsers cannot...
Understand when some contents are updated
on the web
page.
It's very simple, but it's the most important.
It's the only way for...
Let's keep going.
To make rich internet applications.
And other rules.
And another.
And
another time I stay here...
Along the event, I can talk to you about that.
Example...
It's very, very, very easy.
But it's necessary.
Difficult or
impossible navigation with keyboard...
It's a big problem we have, because in
application, don't enable navigate to keyboard.
About the links -- we can...
Avoid using titles.
Names.
Generic names.
Because...
The names...
(speaking Portuguese)
Because when a screen reader is going to read
it, the user will not
understand it appropriately.
So you had better choose a long description.
To
help it out.
About the navigation -- is mainly important
for applications, because...
The other big problem about it is that people
can navigate through tab, but
can never reach the contents.
So you can raise the skip navigation method.
So
you can also use this with CSS, to outline...
Okay.
To kind of highlight the
place where people are navigating through
the keyboard.
So this approach of
skipping the navigation...
Is extremely efficient, but you need to focus
the...
You need to set the focus correctly in the
JavaScript as well.
Because
if you cannot set the focus, when you're going
to navigate it, the focus...
Go
back to or change to a different place.
It can mess everything around.
This is
another example.
That is very cool for you to understand when
you're learning
accessibility.
Two minutes.
(speaking Portuguese)
To think about mobile.
And then they see that it does not work.
Because
some applications, some mobile applications,
do not consider clicking the
events click events.
You can use the touch screen, or even the
keyboard.
This
is another approach, to show the menu.
To open the menu using the keyboard.
And finally, what would be the great (inaudible)
of the accessible
applications?
So here I brought to you the champions.
There were some contests
in Brazil.
So those were the winners.
And you can see that they have that kind
of menu at the top.
The right top.
Or the left top.
From where you can control
the contrast, the font size, or skip to the
content.
So those are really basic
things that your website or your application
should consider.
And so here I
brought you an example of how to control the
font size, increase or decrease
it, how to set the contrast right.
So I wrote a sample of this code, and it's
already on Github for you to contribute if
you want.
It's called side-by-side
JS.
And the creator of the web says we always
need to care about the
standards.
Need to be compatible with them.
And the message I really brought
to you today is that the most important thing
after all is that we need to
know about interactive design.
And I'm sorry that I could not...
I did not
have the time to talk about what?
Can you repeat that?
That's all.
Thank you.
Okay.
So...
We hope you guys enjoyed it.
And...
If you want to know more
about that matter, that topic, you can just
look for us after this.
I...
To be here...
All event.
Yeah, we're going to be here 'til Saturday.
So yeah.
>>(speaking Portuguese)
Make yourself at home.
Thank you.
It'll be a pleasure to get to know you.
Thank you very much.